- So it's nice to see you and
congrats on the little one.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
- How's the family doing, overall?
- So good. She is such a light and a joy
and having a new baby in the house,
like, you know what it's like.
They love her so much and-
- I know, is there any jealousy,
just 'cause it's a new, you know,
taking their time.
- It's weird because
I thought they would
either like, you know, be very mad at her
for just existing.
- Yeah.
- Or they would like want
so much attention from me,
but they actually love her so much
and they want so much attention from me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So it's both and
it's really not, it has a lot to do
with her obviously, but they
still shower her with love,
every bath in the sink, they
crowd around and Miles is in
like this, like this crazy kissing phase
where he's like just kind of
practicing a little bit on
everything.
- Oh my God, no,
but my daughter did that to Remy whenever,
she just kept kissing him,
she just thought he was so cute too
and just kept and I was like,
"baby, it's getting weird."
- I know, I know, I know.
And so Miles is like, if it's like six
in the morning I feel the
kisses and he thinks I'm asleep
but it's so cute. He'll do my
like top lip and bottom lip.
And then with Esti he's
just like "ah!", like
- [Kelly] Yeah
- All in.
- He's like, this feels fine.
- Yeah, he loves it, he's
like so affectionate.
- I heard that y'all actually,
did you throw them a party like
- I did
- before Esti came home?
- Yeah. I had this big grand idea.
So I had a scheduled
C-section, so I thought it
was gonna happen on, like, a
Saturday morning or something,
so I planned this big Scooby-Doo party,
the kids love Scooby-Doo
right now and
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And the old ones only
like, they're very crazy
about it being the old, old ones.
And um, so I bought
balloons and Scooby snacks
and all this stuff for my
bedroom 'cause they love
when they get a chance
to sleep in our bed, so,
I had that planned out, but then of course
the C-section just came out of nowhere
and so I wasn't able to do it
so I did it after she was born
and they were just so,
so happy and I wanted-
- It's such a smart idea
though, for the older kids.
- Yeah. I wanted them to
make, I wanted them to know
that I wasn't gonna forget about them.
- So we just do these special things
- Yeah, and not resent the baby
- Yes, exactly.
- Her name is Esti, which
I thought was so cool.
And I know I found out over text.
Why? 'Cause I asked
but tell everybody where
that name came from.
- Yeah, I was actually just,
we were on vacation where
we got married in Italy and
I was looking up at the hotel
and I kept seeing the Este,
Este of it and then I was like
I love the name Este,
and then just playing around with it,
and then we came up with
Esti, and then John,
after we named her Esti,
learned that it was actually his
great-grandmother's name, so,
- Which is the craziest part of the story.
- Yeah.
- Because I've never heard
this name in my entire life.
And you're like, it's a family name.
- I know.
- No, I'd never heard of Esti.
- [Chrissy] I know.
No, it, it was so, yeah, I
guess it maybe it was Esther
and then they turned it to Esti, but yeah,
- [Kelly] But that's cute.
- Yeah.
- I love that.
I love how it was familiar
- Yeah, yeah.
And then of course I'm
sure you're the same way,
you want them to all sound
good together and have the
- [Kelly] Yes.
- you know, so it's, just fit.
- I was the weird mom who
was like, has to be an R,
cause "River", and "Re-"
- [Chrissy] Yeah.
- I was like, I thought I was cute.
Anyway, but they're great names, anyway.